bienvenue à tous sur LCP Public Sénat
c'est l'heure de parents Hebdo 45
minutes pour faire le tour de
l'actualité politique et parlementaire
avec Michael zaves
cette semaine la quatre coffonies sur
les impôts rien n'est gravé dans le
marbre à estimer le secrétaire d'État au
budget Christian Eckert avant de
rectifier ses propos déclarations
faites-moi d'une semaine après
l'engagement de François Hollande qui a
promis qu'il n'y aurait plus
d'augmentation d'impôts un déjeuné
devenu une affaire d'état le
gouvernement sert leand derrière
Jean-Pierre Jouyet fragilisé par les
propos sur François Fillon qui a été
tenu par des journalistes au monde à
droite on réclame la démission du
secrétaire d'État à l'église et trois
parlementaires dans le viseur de la
justice les députés Bernard brochant
Lucien de Gauchy et le sénateur bruno
Sido il aurait oublié de signaler dans
leur déclaration de patrimoine des avoir
détenus à l'étranger là haute autorité
pour la transparence de la vie publique
a saisi le parquet qui a ouvert des
enquêtes et pour commenter toute cette
actualité très chargée cette semaine
encore notre invité bonjour uno bonjour
Le Roux vous êtes député de le président
du groupe socialiste à l'Assemblée
nationale vous connaissez un peu le
principe de cette émission va dérouler
tout le fil de l'actualité mais votre
portrait est dressé par des
parlementaires vos confrères je vous
laisse les écouter et on débat juste
après voilà un chef qui a fort à faire
avec ces troupes à tel point et j'en en
fais pas une attaque personnelle c'est
pas l'homme qui est visé mais le chef de
groupe à tel point qu'on peut se
demander si par moment il est toujours
bien le chef du groupe il a réussi à
casser quelques bras pour que les
frondeurs soient moins nombreux Matignon
a fait la même chose et l'Élysée
idem mais bon voilà Chef un peu un peu
contesté on n'est pas toujours d'accord
mais c'est quelqu'un qui je reconnais
une force de travail exceptionnelle et
qui à mon avis porte bien les destinés à
notre groupe c'est pas une fonction
facile et le président du groupe
socialiste après j'avais un conseil à
donner à Bruno mais
c'est de comment dire c'est quelqu'un de
fidèle et ça c'est une qualité il est
fidèle au président de la République
depuis très longtemps mais
je pense que l'intérêt y compris des
socialistes c'est parfois que le groupe
socialiste soit plus en interpellation
il est précisé en Europe c'est quelqu'un
d'affable il faut être capable de
rassembler il fait le boulot il est là
parce qu'il faut être présent quand même
au moins 5 jours sur 7 donc il fait bien
son travail je crois il y a eu des
moments difficiles avant l'heure il a eu
comme président de groupe affronté des
situations que d'autres présidents de
groupe n'ont pas connu au fond il s'en
tient pas mal on a toujours réussi à me
faire voter la confiance au gouvernement
avant de le Rhône est allé voir beaucoup
de frondeurs c'est vrai mais quelque
part où j'étais un petit peu maté ces
frondeur je ne me situe pas dans ce
registre mais j'ai dit et ça devrait
répondre en partie autre question qu'il
ne manquerait jamais de majorité au
gouvernement mais bien entendu que ça
veut dire les choses ma responsabilité
c'est de donner une majorité au
gouvernement et de peser de peser parce
que le groupe majoritaire n'est pas là
simplement pour enregistrer il doit
peser sur les décisions et avec Manuel
Valls nous avons d'ailleurs inauguré
peut-être que c'est le temps qui voulait
ça les deux premières années sont plus
la mise en oeuvre des dispositifs qui
ont été ceux de la campagne
présidentielle avec Manuel Valls il y a
une concertation de tous les moments
parce qu'il sait que c'est nécessaire
oui mais je pense que c'est le temps
dans ce quinquennat qui a changé il y
avait moins de concertation sur ce qui
était
issu de la campagne présidentielle des
engagements oui bien entendu mais c'est
une concertation à l'époque je vous
réponds précisément que les deux
premières années sont des temps de mise
en oeuvre de décision que nous avons
pris collectivement dans le cadre d'une
campagne et donc il y a moins de
concertation à voir de façon obligatoire
Manuel Valls c'est qu'il arrive dans un
moment qui était difficile où il doit
lui-même mettre sa propre marque où il a
un groupe parlementaire qui n'avait
peut-être pas ou il n'a pas les mêmes
points d'appui et donc il a décidé
d'avoir une concertation étroite avec le
groupe je m'en félicite et d'ailleurs
nous trouvons les accords sur tous les
textes et donc pour ramener aux fondeur
il n'y a pas de problème de frondeur il
y a aujourd'hui des frondeurs mais il ne
pose aucun problème car jamais la
majorité ne manquera au gouvernement
d'autres problèmes en revanche on va
voir la semaine en images depuis le
week-end et lundi encore on n'a jamais
autant parlé d'un déjeuner
un déjeuner à Paris entre un secrétaire
général de l'Élysée et un ex 1er
ministre et des révélations sur une
demande supposée de François Fillon à
Jean-Pierre jouyer c'est ce que dit un
livre de deux journalistes du Monde
confrontés à cette affaire le
gouvernement serrant Jean-Baptiste
Daoulas
l'image est symbolique un longue aparté
entre Manuel Valls et Jean-Pierre Jouyet
après le conseil des ministres le signe
que l'exécutif soutient un secrétaire
général de l'Élysée dans la tourmente
françois Hollande veut garder son plus
proche collaborateur et les ministres
sont privés de le faire savoir c'est
quelqu'un qui a des qui a des valeurs et
voilà il avance il est au travail
sereinement voilà il est secrétaire
général de l'isé Monsieur douka donc il
le reste et il était là ce matin au
Conseil des ministres la majorité attend
que la polémique dégonfle mais l'UMP
demande des comptes après les
revirements de Jean-Pierre Jouyet sur
les accusations portées contre François
Fillon
pensez-vous sérieusement que Monsieur
jouillet ait pu agir de la sorte sans
avoir reçu les instructions du président
de la République
Monsieur juillet a commis une véritable
forfaiture nous demandons solennellement
sa démission à deux reprises Manuel
Valls le Premier ministre rappelle le
climat de suspicion et les rivalités au
sein même de l'UMP comment ne pas
rappeler les déclarations le 20 juillet
dernier de François Fillon j'ouvre les
guillemets nous sommes frappés par un
scandale financier majeur au juge de
faire la lumière nous en tirons les
conséquences ensuite disaient-ils dans
le journal Le Monde sachez que vous
n'entraînerez pas le président de la
République le Gouvernement et la
majorité dans ces polémiques qui ne sont
pas à la hauteur de la tente des
Français
Manuel Valls se rend coup pour coup mais
pas une seule fois il ne prononcera le
nom de Jean-Pierre jouillet mais c'est
tout simple Jean-Pierre juillet est
indéfendable ils n'ont donc pas été
défendu par le Premier ministre donc
nous sommes tout à fait déterminés à
l'UMP de continuer à agir pour que on
est enfin les réponses que nous
attendons de la part de la présidence de
la République et du gouvernement l'UMP
fait bloc contre l'exécutif pour
l'instant les riv alités entre Sarkozy
stéonistes restent silencieuse mais en
coulisses les proches de Nicolas Sarkozy
ne croirait pas aux dénégation de
François Fillon
ce déjeuner ses conséquences politiques
on en parle tout de suite c'est le zoom
de la semaine
et nous accueillons Denis Jean Bart
bonjour éditorialise politique alors
dites nous cette affaire c'est un peu
calmé pour vous est-ce que c'est une
affaire internale UMP une affaire d'état
ou une simple affaire qui finira par
faire chier je trouve que à faire des
tests c'est un bien bien grand mot
pourquoi est-ce qu'il est anormal que le
secrétaire général de l'Élysée des
jeunes avec un ancien Premier ministre
et un ancien collaborateur du Premier
ministre qui a été lui-même son
collaborateur à la Caisse des Dépôts
puisqu'il était son adjoint il me semble
que dans la République française il y a
rien de choquant là-dedans et en plus
c'est de passer creux puisque c'était
dans un lieu public j'imagine en tout
cas j'espère que Bruno Leroux parfois
des jeunes avec des parlementaires de
l'opposition et je trouve ça assez
normal le dialogue républicain donc
c'est pas vraiment en soi une affaire
d'état la deuxième chose est ce qu'il
était anormal qui ne part de l'actualité
de l'actualité et de politique je serai
surpris du contraire moi je ne sais pas
exactement ce qui s'est dit dans ce
déjeuner et qui parle de la qualité
c'est pourquoi Jean-Pierre jouillet en
parle à des journalistes pourquoi il
révèle ça ça fait partie d'un déjeuner
quel est ce que c'est de la naïveté
est-ce que c'est du calcul ça c'est une
vraie question et on a besoin d'avoir
une une réponse là-dessus la deuxième
chose c'est que il y a quelque chose
aussi d'assez surprenant qu'on a passé
mis en avant c'est que pour la première
fois des journalistes révèlent leur
source donc ils mettent même en
difficulté leur propre interlocuteurs
est-ce que c'est normal que les
journalistes
je pense que chacun doit être dans son
rôle le rôle des journalistes c'est
d'analyser c'est de rechercher des
informations ou de dévoiler des choses
mais quand il y a des connexions et
c'est là que je pense et que j'ai assumé
depuis le début une part de maladresse
parce que je pense que dans les premiers
mais de la part de Jean-Pierre juillet
je l'ai dit je pense que son premier
propos il y a eu une volonté de
préserver de préserver François Fillon
sur la discussion qui avait mais ce
déjeuner plutôt qu'une maladresse non je
pense qu'il n'y a pas d'erreur je pense
que moi qu'il y a une simple maladresse
je pense qu'il est normal qu'il est il
est déjeuner je pense qu'ils sont sains
je pense qu'il est saint de ne pas
vouloir raconter ensuite les déjeuner et
la nécessité totalement la nécessité
donc je pense qu'il n'y a pas de de
raison de raconter ensuite les choses
mais pour le reste qui peut penser
surtout ayant lu le livre sur les
confidences de Nicolas Sarkozy sur ce
qu'il dit les uns et des autres de
François Fillon qui peut imaginer qu'au
moment où avait lieu ce déjeuner il
n'est pas été question de l'UMP qu'il
n'est pas été question des contes de
l'UMP qu'il n'est pas été question de la
campagne de Nicolas Sarkozy je ne crois
pas une minute
c'est le problème c'est que je perd
jouait à Comines maladresse en disant
une chose un jour le contraire
de protéger dans un premier temps et
puis qu'il y a un en qui se met en place
et que d'une maladresse on voudrait
faire une affaire qui est une affaire de
machination éventuelles machination les
proches de François mais mais c'est vrai
que les conséquences politiques sont
pourjouillées après tout c'est en
fonctionnaire et c'est un fusible qui
peut sauter c'est pas très grave qui
peut sauter enfin peu importe où ils
sautera pas c'est pas très grave mais en
revanche pour François Fillon s'est
révélations sont très lourdes vous savez
que quand vous êtes projeté comme ça
dans une affaire on en parle beaucoup
mais même si ça se termine bien on en
parlera beaucoup moins or c'est un homme
qui veut dire affronter des difficultés
énormes depuis quelques mois qui était
très populaire à la sortie de du dernier
quinquennat qui apparaissait comme le
futur candidat à l'élection
présidentielle qui a voulu affronter la
Jean-François Copé et qui en est sorti
en lambeaux comme Jean-François Copé
d'ailleurs et qui aujourd'hui essaie de
se reconstruire en proposant on peut
être pour ou contre ça un vrai programme
c'est au fond peut-être le seul qui vaut
à l'heure actuelle travaille sur un
programme on peut être tout à fait
contre parce que et en débattre parce
que ça semble très tâche rien et très
loin au fond de ces bases politiques
c'est guinnistes mais au fond de tout ça
a été effacé par cette affaire-là et
donc lui il a subi des conséquences très
lourdes en tout cas tout ramène à la
bataille de la droite et cette affaire
une absolument il y aurait eu il y
aurait eu y avoir un problème sur ce
déjeuner si il avait donné lieu à une
intervention sur le cours d'une affaire
et là cela aurait été quelque chose de
particulièrement grave sur lequel
d'ailleurs je l'ai dit le secrétaire
général s'il y avait eu après le
déjeuner retour à l'Elysée pour
intervenir et demander au président
d'intervenir sur une affaire pour
essayer davantage et l'un ou l'autre
dans l'opposition cela aurait été un
véritable scandale
c'est là qu'il peut y avoir un débat
d'interprétation sur ce moi je pense
qu'il n'y a pas eu de vrai demande parce
qu'il savait que cette demande ne serait
pas et quand on ne fait pas de demande
au secrétaire général de l'Élysée quand
on sait qu'elle n'a aucune chance
d'aboutir et bien plus intelligent je
pense que c'était un déjeuner aller pour
tout vous dire je pense que c'est un
déjeuner où ils se sont beaucoup moqués
beaucoup moqués très certainement de
Nicolas Sarkozy beaucoup moqué de la
situation dans laquelle il avait mis et
le pays et l'UMP et ils avaient été
chacun en responsabilité et on sait très
bien quand Jean-Pierre Jouyet a quitté
le gouvernement c'est en partie à cause
de la personnalité de la politique menée
par Nicolas Sarkozy il pensait être sur
une mission l'Europe il avait je crois
des bons rapports et François Fillon et
donc ils avaient dans ce déjeuner je
pense quelques raisons de regarder avec
un sourire de là en faire une affaire de
dire je suis une victime mais il n'y a
aucune victime Nicolas Sarkozy veut
toujours se victimiser
il faut bien dire que pour Nicolas
Sarkozy c'est pour la première fois
depuis des mois une situation un peu
confortable il peut se faire passer pour
une victime voilà donc il a pas manqué
d'ailleurs d'exploiter la situation sans
dénoncer François Fillon ce qui est une
habileté jamais ne négligé vous le savez
merci Denis Jobard pour cet éclairage
sur ce fameux déjeuner et on passe à
mardi place au commémorations du 11
novembre
et cette année la France a célébré le
centenaire de la Grande Guerre 14-18
François Fillon a inauguré François
Hollande pardon a inaugurer un nouveau
mémorial à Notre-Dame de Lorette dans
l'Est l'anneau de la mémoire consacrée à
tous les morts de la guerre quelle que
soit leur nationalité le président
appelé à la mobilisation avec ce message
le patriotisme n'est pas une nostalgie
c'est une volonté
toujours les parlementaires français
relâche qui n'étaient pas le cas au
niveau européen et notamment de la Cour
de justice européenne à la sanctionné ce
que l'on appelle le tourisme social en
clair les immigrés ne pourront plus
exiger des prestations sociales sans
chercher un travail la Constitution
française est très claire Bruno Leroux
on a un principe qui est le principe de
l'égalité ça veut dire que ce qui a été
décidé par la Cour de justice européenne
ne peut pas s'appliquer sur le
territoire français très clairement
pourquoi parce qu'à partir du moment où
il y a une certaine légalité on ne met
en France il y a aujourd'hui pour
bénéficier de prestations sociales dans
notre pays il faut y être installé et
avoir un certain nombre de droit il ne
peut pas y avoir et moi j'ai regardé
avec attention cet élément parce qu'il
force aujourd'hui l'Union européenne à
réfléchir à la question de
l'harmonisation sociale dans les
différents pays et qu'il n'est pas
possible de venir dans un pays la
liberté de circulation est totale mais
impossible d'y venir uniquement dans le
but de prétendre sans pouvoir subvenir à
ses besoins et uniquement dans le but de
prétendre à une prestation sociale les
étrangers doivent avoir le même accès
aux soins pour tous et bien mais ce
n'est pas une question la d'accès aux
soins bien entendu depuis le Moyen-âge
nous avons dans notre pays une tradition
de de soigner dans les hospices en
accueillait les indigents aujourd'hui et
c'est pour cela d'ailleurs qu'il a une
grande confusion dans la façon dont
l'opposition à bord se débat en essayant
de mélanger l'aide médicale d'État de
dénoncer l'aide médicale d'État qui est
en fin de compte ça n'a rien à voir et
ça n'a rien à voir avec cela et la
France sera toujours fidèle à la
tradition qui a été la sienne et les
médecins seront toujours fidèles au
serment qu'ils ont fait de soigner
quel que soit celui qui se présente
devant eux et ils continueront à le
faire la seule modification c'est que ce
qui était à la charge directe des
hôpitaux avant a été pris depuis
quelques années en charge par l'État
avec l'aide médicale qui représente
c'est vrai un budget mais qui représente
aussi une véritable politique de santé
publique en prenant en charge ceux qui
sont sur notre territoire et qui ont
besoin d'être soignés nous préservons
aussi
ce qui est le soin dans notre pays et la
capacité à prendre en main des
contagions à prendre en main et donc
c'est une véritable santé publique une
politique de santé publique
nous avions depuis le début priorité
national vous connaissez ce mot et il
n'y a aucune raison d'aller sur une
priorité nationale l'arrêt peut être
commentée de ce point de vue là mais les
œillères du Front national ne lisent pas
le bon arrêt cet arrêt dit simplement
qu'il ne peut pas y avoir aujourd'hui de
circulation
intra-européenne uniquement dans le but
d'avoir accès à des prestations sociales
dans les pays qui sont forcément les
plus avancés de ce point de vue il n'y a
absolument aucune forme de priorité
nationale la libre circulation reste la
règle reste la règle et mercredi on
parle d'un autre sujet le budget et la
question des impôts
à la table du Conseil des ministres le
budget rectificatif de la France celui
de 2014 des modifications en effet été
apportées comme chaque année notamment
en raison du nouveau dérapage du déficit
public et aussi pour permettre une
hausse jusqu'à 20 % pour les de la taxe
d'habitation pour les résidences
secondaires elles a mandingava
le projet de loi de finances
rectificative c'est ce que l'on appelle
la voiture balai budgétaire chargée de
rééquilibrer un budget à la fin de
l'année et il est placé sous le signe de
la morosité de l'économie française très
faible croissance très faible inflation
dans ce contexte le gouvernement a donc
maintenu les prévisions macroéconomiques
qu'il avait adopté début septembre dans
le PLFR une croissance de 0,4% et une
affiliation hors tabac de 0,5 % il
commence par une mauvaise nouvelle le
dérapage du déficit de l'État le déficit
du budget de l'État continue à croître
par rapport à la dépression de 4
milliards d'après les documents du
budget rectificatif c'est un signal
envoyé à Bruxelles il contient de
nouvelles mesures de réduction des
déficits à hauteur de 3,6 milliards
d'euros taux d'intérêt de la dette plus
bas que prévu et recettes de lutte
contre la fraude fiscale meilleure
qu'annoncée mais aussi des mesures plus
polémiques comme la possibilité donnée
aux communes confrontées à un marché
immobilier tendu de surtex et les
résidences secondaires une mesure vue
comme une ultime entorse à la pose
fiscale promise par le chef de l'État
jeudi dernier devient nous entendre de
du président de la République qu'il
promettait de ne pas augmenter les
impôts sauf la taxe d'habitation sur les
résidences secondaires pour les autres
tendues ou devions-nous entendre qu'il
ne s'agissait une fois de plus que d'une
fausse promesse le ministre des Finances
a tenu à rassurer c'est vraiment très
partiel sur une partie du territoire à
la demande des communes et pour les
finances des communes et en aucun cas
les finances de l'État ni dans la loi de
finance pour 2015 ni dans la loi de
finances rectificatif pour 2014 il n'y a
aucune disposition augmentant les impôts
de l'ensemble des Français l'État a
aussi dû réajuster son budget en raison
de dépenses plus importante que prévu
dans ces opérations extérieures et pour
certaines prestations de solidarité
Bercy a annulé 2 milliards d'euros de
crédit dans différents ministères le
PLFR 2014 sera débattu dans l'hémicycle
à partir du 1er décembre
alors dans ce budget rectificatif il y a
donc la question de cette taxe
d'habitation qui pourrait augmenter
finalement elle ne rapporterait selon
certains calculs que 150 millions
d'euros tout ça pour ça est-ce que ça
vaut le coup d'alourdir la fiscalité
pour la première fois où je vois un
reportage qui explique si bien les
choses d'habitude on dit c'est une taxe
nouvelle c'est un impôt qui va être créé
non c'est les communes qui ont
aujourd'hui des logements vacants
notamment des communes comme Paris qui
ont beaucoup d'étrangers de personnes
qui vivent à l'extérieur et qui ont un
logement à Paris où elles viennent de
temps en temps et bien ces logements
vacants ils empêchent aujourd'hui ils
font monter les prix ils empêchent
aujourd'hui une partie des habitants de
se loger on connaît le même problème en
savoir en Haute-Savoie
5% d'augmentation non non ça cible 5% du
territoire et c'est un outil qui est
donné aux élus locaux pour essayer
d'avoir à eux de choisir et donc ce
n'est absolument pas le budget de l'État
nous donnons un outil aux élus dans une
petite
partie des communes françaises et donc
il n'y a absolument n'a aucune
augmentation d'impôts pour les Français
aucune absolument aucune une bonne
nouvelle quand même cette semaine au
troisième de semestre la croissance va
augmenter un tout petit peu à chiffre de
0,3 % Satisfaction quand même pas de
quoi sauter au plafond ça reste quand
même la race continue d'augmenter de
toute façon ça reste très faible mais
les efforts payent l'Allemagne
augmente beaucoup moins et toujours dans
une difficulté et elle devrait continuer
à se poser nous sommes dans un dialogue
que j'estime fructueux avec l'Allemagne
des annonces ont été faites en matière
d'investissement elle doit aller plus
loin maintenant pour participer avec son
excédent à la relance européenne mais ce
qui se passe en France mérite d'être
conforté vous savez si les prévisions
sont meilleures que celles qui étaient
faites c'est le delta c'est la politique
du gouvernement et si aujourd'hui nos
prévisions et ceux qui s'est passé les
annonces qui ont été faites son meilleur
que qui était prévu il y a quelques mois
c'est tout simplement parce que nous
maintenons l'effort sur la compétitivité
des entreprises
34100 suppression nette de poste sur ce
troisième trimestre quand même
destruction d'emploi pour être précis
oui cela montre qu'aujourd'hui il faut
continuer à faire en sorte d'adapter
notre appareil productif de renforcer
l'effort sur la compétitivité et de
donner la possibilité aux entreprises
d'aller conquérir de nouveaux marchés et
si nous sommes en situation un peu plus
favorable c'est le résultat de la
politique depuis deux ans
puisque Christian écarte le secrétaire
d'État au budget a laissé sous-entendre
que la pose fiscale n'était pas gravée
dans le marbre réécoutez ces propos
c'était ce jeudi 12 novembre sur RTL
on peut pas gravé dans le marbre une
situation qui dépend d'un contexte
international qui dépend d'un contexte
international que nous ne maîtrisons pas
qui avait prévu il y a 6-8 mois une
aussi faible inflation en Europe
président de la République il a donné un
cap et vous dites que bah ça dépend de
la situation
vous savez parfois il faut tirer
quelques bords
le même Christian et carte a fait trois
déclarations différentes on a du mal à
comprendre pourquoi un tel tumulte une
telle cacophonie sur un sujet aussi
important quand il y a une
incompréhension adressez-vous à ceux qui
votent c'est au Parlement qui est voté
l'impôt et c'est dépend du Parlement et
je peux vous dire comme président du
groupe majoritaire que les engagements
du Président seront scrupuleusement
respectés et qu'il n'y aura à partir de
2015 aucun impôts
ne peut pas être pire que celui qu'il
est aujourd'hui
moyen de se passer de ce contrat
et si je vous annonçais là maintenant ce
que je ne ferai pas bien entendu mais
que le contrat est respecté vous me
poseriez la question mais est-ce que
l'on doit renier aujourd'hui ce que sont
les valeurs de notre pays ce qu'est la
position européenne vis-à-vis
mais
nous avons dit de façon très claire
depuis le début qu'il y a des conditions
à remplir pour que ces navires puissent
être livrés à la Russie je ne vois pas
aujourd'hui la Russie dans une position
plus conciliante au contraire je vois je
vois de graveries en Ukraine aujourd'hui
je vois une Russie qui visiblement ne
comprend pas ce que veulent dire les
règles internationales mais je dis qu'en
même temps les conditions ne sont pas
remplies pour aujourd'hui livrer ces
deux navires je reviens un petit peu sur
l'agenda parlementaire Bruno Leroux le
28 novembre prochain il y aura une
proposition de résolution qui va passer
à l'Assemblée nationale pour reconnaître
l'État de Palestine vulcontexte vu qu'on
parle de troisième Intifada qui sera en
train de se créer notamment et la
Palestine est-ce que vous croyez
vraiment que c'est le bon moment pour
faire passer ce genre de résolution mais
peut-être que j'ai cru que la question
que vous allez me poser c'était pour ne
le faites-vous pas un peu trop tard je
pense que c'est nécessaire aujourd'hui
et que il doit y avoir une prise de
conscience partout dans le monde de tous
les auteurs et notamment de la France
qui dans la diplomatie occupe une place
importante qu'il doit y avoir
réouverture des processus d'un processus
de la droite peuvent être avec vous mais
j'espère qu'il me reste
j'appelle tout le monde à donner de la
force à la diplomatie française et je
pense que ce que nous allons faire
d'ailleurs en lien avec la diplomatie
française à l'Élysée est un texte
d'équilibre est un texte qui appuie sur
la nécessaire sécurité de l'État
d'Israël sur la capacité qu'il doit
avoir à vivre en paix pas simplement
avec ceux qui sont à côté les
Palestiniens mais avec tous ceux qui
sont dans la région et donc c'est un
texte de paix c'est un texte de paix je
crois qu'il y a besoin de cette
initiative elle doit donner de la force
à la diplomatie française et donc
j'appelle à ce que nous la votion
massivement dans l'hémicycle on va
rester à l'Assemblée nationale Bruno Le
Rouge avait certainement entendu lors
des questions d'actualité
notamment monsieur d'orugy qui est le
co-président du groupe des Verts à
l'Assemblée nationale qui a évoqué le
cas de Stevens qui a posé une question
au ministre de l'intérieur c'est avec le
monde a fait sortir des écoutes
notamment des PV des gendarmes qui a eu
lieu après la mort notamment de Rémi
fresque je vous propose d'écouter
monsieur de Rugy et répondait il posait
la question à Bernard casino le ministre
de l'Intérieur
faut-il croire le préfet du Tarn qui
déclare qu'il n'avait je cite donné
aucune consigne de sévérité aux forces
de l'ordre ou le commandant du
groupement de gendarmerie qui indique
sur procès-verbal avoir reçu du préfet
la consigne de faire preuve je cite de
nouveau d'une extrême fermeté et en
attendant les résultats de l'enquête
Bernard cazena interdit l'usage des
grenades offensives et annoncé que les
opérations de maintien de l'ordre au
risque serait filmé Bruno Leroux est-ce
que ce sont des mesures un peu trop
radicales est-ce que ça va suffire je
pense que le ministre le ministre de
l'Intérieur et absolument dans une
réponse parfaite à la situation qui est
créée par cette tragédie il a donné tous
les éléments et bien entendu qu'ils
devaient le faire pour que l'enquête
puisse se mener dès que le drame a été
connu et s'il y a aujourd'hui des
écoutes des PV qui ont été faits c'est
bien parce que tout a remis à la justice
pour qu'elle puisse déterminer les
responsabilités aujourd'hui l'enquête
est menée elle peut apparaître trop
longue à certains il faut prendre des
mesures et des mesures qui parce que
nous avons une première certitude c'est
que cette mort a été causée par une
grenade offensive il faut qu'il y ait à
titre conservatoire ou même voir ensuite
plus loin ce sera au ministre de le dire
mais une suspension de ce type de
munition dont on a vu aujourd'hui
qu'elles ont tué
les vers réclament une commission
d'enquête parlementaire est-ce que vous
êtes prêts à accorder cette commission
d'enquête
une commission d'enquête parlementaire
ne peut pas enquêter bien entendu tout
dépend tout dépend de l'objet de la
commission d'enquête mais une commission
d'enquête parlementaire ne peut pas se
substituer à la justice et moi je fais
confiance à la justice pour qu'elle dise
en tout cas il n'y a pas eu de demande
de commission d'enquête elle n'a pas été
déposée à l'Assemblée mais une
commission d'enquête qui viserait à
pouvoir vous savez quand il y a des pots
de commission enquête on doit demander
on doit demander à la garde des sceaux
s'il y a sur le sujet de la commission
d'enquête une procédure judiciaire à
l'évidence si la commission d'enquête
portait sur les faits qui sont ceux sur
lesquels la justice enquête la garde des
sceaux nous répondrait qu'il y a
aujourd'hui une enquête menée judiciaire
dans cette affaire donc il ne peut pas y
avoir de commission d'enquête donc moi
je fais confiance à la justice j'espère
qu'elle pourra aller le plus vite
possible pour l'instant tout dépend un
petit peu de la nomination de cette
commission point d'interrogation
on va parler maintenant
d'un rapport qui était au Sénat qui a
lieu avec d'intense discussions et pour
cause les thèmes qui ont été abordés
dans ce rapport sont loin de faire
l'unanimité chez les Sénateurs on y
parle de la lutte contre les
discriminations c'est un rapport qui a
été voté mais évidemment sous conditions
un soulagement après le débat ou le de
la semaine dernière en commission des
lois qui a opposé pendant plus de deux
heures les sénateurs de tout bord il y a
eu des abstentions et de contre mais bon
ça a été voté il faut mesurer les
discriminations pour pouvoir et lutter
contre et voir pourquoi la
discrimination va de l'école jusqu'à la
vie professionnelle aujourd'hui on ne
mesure pas donc on peut faire semblant
de ne pas savoir principal proposition
l'introduction dans le recensement d'une
question sur le pays de naissance des
parents et la nationalité antérieure
autre proposition développer les carrés
confessionnels dans les cimetières la
France compterait aujourd'hui moins de
240 musulmans dont la plupart en
Île-de-France pour lutter contre le
délit de faciès un récépissé pourrait
être établi lors des contrôles
d'identité les deux parlementaires
proposent un renforcement de
l'enseignement du fait religieux dès
l'école primaire
une proposition qui a provoqué une
montée en flèche des débats
de l'islam dans notre société à l'heure
actuelle vous avez compris que ça passe
pas par un enseignement générique si
c'est cela on sort une artillerie lourde
pour pour un problème qui sert est
important qui encore une fois je pense
nécessite pas autant de autant de de
débauche de moyens le gouvernement
c'était engagé en 2012 à revoir sa
politique d'intégration et de lutte
contre les discriminations l'avenir dira
s'il trouvera quelques inspirations dans
ce rapport
de tension dans ce rapport c'était qu'il
voulait faire aussi des statistiques
d'origine c'est ce que propose François
Fillon dans le Figaro Magazine cette
semaine il propose plein d'autres choses
il propose la politique des quotas
nouveau traité de Schengen qu'est-ce que
ça vous inspire tout ça c'est François
Fillon et dans dans la bataille dont
nous parlions tout à l'heure sur une
stratégie l'immigration une stratégie de
segmentation politique il a décidé de
tirer à droite
que d'autres ont décidé dans la semaine
les déclarations sur le mariage pour
tous d'essayer de gérer plutôt à gauche
donc là
à droite comme c'est une stratégie
politique totalement interne au débat de
la droite donc sur le fond parce que ça
fait plusieurs années que je me pose la
question par exemple sur la question les
statistiques je veux lutter contre les
discriminations et donc je me suis posé
la question clairement de savoir si
c'était un bon outil pour l'instant j'ai
répondu non à cette question il me
semble que c'est un outil aujourd'hui
qui en dehors de la connaissance et donc
des universitaires puissent travailler
dans des champs avec un certain nombre
oui les études universitaires mais dans
le champ politique la question des
statistiques aujourd'hui ethniques me
semblerait être un outil de
stigmatisation plus qu'un outil de lutte
contre les discriminations les cottages
n'y suis pas favorable non plus je suis
favorable à ce que nous discutions de la
politique d'immigration ça devrait être
un débat apaisé un débat public au
Parlement sur lequel nous pouvons
arriver à des objectif arrivé à comparer
par rapport et à donner des directions à
faire partager avec le gouvernement aux
Français la réalité de la politique que
nous menons parce qu'il y a une
politique migratoire qui est celle de la
France mais elle est trop souvent
caricaturée caché ou donc nous
gagnerions à avoir un débat public pour
cette question tout à l'heure que vous
dites que il fait il fait un
segmentation politique vers la droite
vers la droite ou vers carrément
l'extrême droite je pense qu'il essaye
oui on parle français Fillon je pense
que vous savez les différences sont
assez tenues pour sur un certain nombre
de sujets aujourd'hui et les porosités
sont énormes entre la droite et
l'extrême droite et donc bien entendu
ces questions là comme François Fillon
je peine toujours à dire que dans le
débat politique il est dangereux
d'ouvrir des idées mais enfin là on voit
bien qu'il y a nécessité à les maîtriser
ses idées quand c'est uniquement des
signaux qui sont lancés comme ça pour
essayer d'attirer oui je les interprète
comme des signaux d'abord parce qu'ils
ne sont pas la réalité qui était celle
de François Fillon il y a quelques
années et donc je ne sais pas si c'est
et je crois que c'est plus la situation
à l'intérieur de l'UMP que la situation
réelle du pays qu'il le fait aller
aujourd'hui braconnet sur ces terres
juste peut-être une réaction par rapport
aux propositions moi s'il y a un
enseignement sur lequel je pense que
nous devrions tous nous mettre d'accord
c'est l'enseignement de la laïcité la
laïcité la laïcité la laïcité et la
seule et la vraie réponse aujourd'hui à
toutes les questions qui peuvent se
poser aujourd'hui de vivre ensemble et
notamment de la place du fait religieux
dans notre pays donc c'est axiome on a
bien compris et je dis on parle des on
reparle même des comptes suisses de
certains parlementaires
ils sont trois dans l'oeil de la justice
selon la Haute autorité pour la
transparence de la vie publique les
députés Bernard brochant Lucien de
Gauchy et le sénateur Bruno aussi
de déclarer certains comptes à
l'étranger Julie Hulin
l'affaire rappelle celle de Jérôme
Cahuzac mais cette fois-ci c'est la
droite qui est touchée les députés
Bernard brochant Lucien de Gauchy et le
sénateur bruno Sido trois parlementaires
UMP épinglé pour avoir dissimulé des
comptes bancaires à l'étranger la Haute
autorité pour la transparence annonce
avoir saisi le parquet de Paris qui a
ouvert des enquêtes préliminaires le
sénateur bruno Sido a confirmé avoir
détenu un compte en Suisse qu'il a
régularisé en 2013 si il est désormais
en règle il n'est pas à l'abri de
poursuites judiciaires il s'agit d'une
situation qui n'est pas une situation
délinquante qui est une situation qui
aujourd'hui non seulement a été
régularisée mais dans laquelle aucune
partie n'a été lézée le député Lucien
Gauchy confirme lui aussi l'existence
d'un compte
en Suisse sang et 200000 euros quant à
Bernard brochant ancien maire de Cannes
son compte ouvert en Suisse pourrait
avoir un solde dépassant le million
d'euros ces trois parlementaires
risquent jusqu'à trois ans de prison
45000 euros d'amende et 10 ans
d'innéligibilité à l'avenir d'autres
affaires pourraient éclater l'examen des
déclarations de patrimoine par la Haute
Autorité de transparence n'étant pas
terminée
alors l'enquête est en cours mais vous
avez appelé Bruno Leroux à la démission
de ces trois parlementaires est-ce que
votre appel inclut aussi ton maternel je
veux avoir une position je n'ai pas
appelé à la démission des trois
parlementaires je veux avoir moi une
position qui soit la même quel que soit
les affaires et quel que soit les élus
d'abord il y a un processus de
vérification parce que nous avons voté
une loi et donc nous faisons aujourd'hui
des déclarations qui sont vérifiées et
où il y a des véritables enquêtes moi
j'ai reçu une lettre de la Haute
autorité qui m'a dit votre déclaration a
été vérifiée elle n'appelle aucun
commentaire elle va être envoyée à la
préfecture de votre département pour
être consulté par les citoyens qui
souhaitent le faire parlementaires
aujourd'hui
la justice doit bien entendu et elle est
la seule à pouvoir dire s'il y a des
irrégularités mais que s'il y a des
irrégularités il ne peut pas y avoir
d'élus fraudeur à l'Assemblée nationale
ou au Sénat et plus de tomates à la
démission pour tous les élus mes tomates
nous vous m'avez déjà pas interroger et
donc vous n'avez pas besoin de le
refaire j'avais dit que je souhaitais sa
démission de l'Assemblée nationale et je
le redis pour tous les élus qui seraient
convaincus après bien entendu que la
justice et puis le dire qui serait qui
aurait été convaincu de fraude le canard
écrivait il y a quelques semaines qui
avait 60 parlementaires qui étaient dans
l'œil du cyclone du fisc vous allez donc
avoir des cas qui vont se renouveler
qu'est-ce que vous allez faire je je
veux encore là-dessus les trucs très
clair il y a les 60 parlementaires dont
parlait la totalité il n'est question
que de parlementaire pour lesquelles il
y a des interrogations et des
vérifications ça ne veut pas dire des
culpabilités mais j'aurais mais c'est
bien pour ça que j'ai voulu réagir sur
un principe j'aurai le même principe sur
tous les cas qui peuvent arriver à
partir du moment où il y a fraude et ce
n'est pas à moi de déterminer s'il y a
fraude c'est à la Haute Autorité par la
transmission parquet et ensuite à la
justice de dire les choses anticiper un
petit peu les choses mais je n'ai pas
rien à anticiper j'attends que la
justice et il y aurait rien exactement
traitement politique à avoir sur ces
questions ici des élus ont été pris en
flagrant délit de fraude aujourd'hui
dans la déclaration qu'ils ont fait à la
totorité il doit y avoir la même
conséquence et la conséquence pour moi
c'est qu'il ne peut pas être possible de
faire la loi quand on ne l'a pas
respecté alors je dis toujours on parle
de l'udei qui a trouvé son président
Jean-Christophe Lagarde élu président du
parti avec plus de 53% des voix loin
devant Hervé Morin un mot peut-être sur
le gagnant
dans le cadre des rapports républicains
il a même pu
exister les déjeuner entre nous voilà
les fameux déjeuners donc nous n'avons
pas fait depuis très longtemps avec
Jean-Christophe mais je pense que ça
fait partie de la nécessaire du
nécessaire dialogue républicain je tiens
le féliciter je tiens à le féliciter
pour son élection et je vais lui dire
que bien entendu dans le cadre
républicain qui est l'autre il se situe
dans l'opposition nous assumons
aujourd'hui la majorité j'espère que
nous aurons le meilleur dialogue et
j'espère que la génération qui est la
sienne peut participer à ce qui est d'un
dialogue plus au fond peut-être avec
moins de posture c'est en tout cas le
fort le souhait que je forme après cette
élection une question sur votre partie
congrès de 5 du 5 au 7 juin 2015 trop
tôt trop tard cela a été décidé par le
premier secrétaire je pensais que nous
aurions pu faire un congrès plutôt il
s'avère que statutairement c'est la
première date où il est possible parce
que je crois que nous avons besoin
aujourd'hui de nous réorganiser et que
l'organisation d'un parti politique est
quelque chose d'important qu'il y a des
débats que nous devons trancher beaucoup
aujourd'hui d'élus qui disent nous ne
sommes pas d'accord avec ce que fait le
gouvernement ou de militants qui disent
là aimerait voir ces choses tranchées
dans un congrès il y a besoin de
soutenir le gouvernement et pour
soutenir le gouvernement il faut se
mettre en ordre pour le faire ah mais la
bonne date c'est forcément celle qui a
été choisie
moi je ne suis pas en charge des
contraintes
et donc j'aurais souhaité que nous
puissions le faire en février ou en mars
prochain mais l'assemblée impossible à
mettre en oeuvre pour respecter un
calendrier qui est très strict dans
l'organisation des congrès
Jean-Christophe Cambadélis dit que la
première date possible et celle de juin
2015 et donc c'est la date que nous
assumons tous aujourd'hui pour avoir ce
débat sur lequel j'appelle à la grande
responsabilité un congrès du parti
majoritaire quand on est au pouvoir
c'est un exercice qui n'est pas facile
mais un exercice qui est important
socialiste et donc je conseillerais à
tous mes amis de regarder aussi
l'extérieur de regarder la situation du
pays et il n'y aurait rien de pire que
un congrès qui ne soit pas en phase avec
la réalité que vit la France et les
Français
à quoi rêvent notre jeunesse est un
documentaire qui s'y intéresse de très
près il vient de sortir en salle aussi
mais il a le doigt même le droit à une
projection privée à l'Élysée ça
s'appelle chante ton bac d'abord et tout
ça vous est raconté par Simon barbarie
dans une autre direction je veux dire
des crises économiques on est toujours
eu il y aura tout le temps on est pas
sérieux quand on a 17 ans et même la
crise économique ne parvient pas à faire
déchanter la jeunesse chanter c'est bien
de ça donc il s'agit dans le
documentaire de David André chante ton
bac d'abord chronique poétique des rêves
et des angoisses d'une bande de lycéens
de Boulogne-sur-Mer face à l’éternel
rite de passage du baccalauréat est-ce
que le monde a changé
ce que l'on va changer fort de son
succès critique l'équipe du film a été
reçu cette semaine par un spectateur
inattendu François Hollande touché lui
aussi par les affres de cette jeunesse
boulonnaise
vous êtes à cheval
c'est un geste qui est qui est
formidable pour ces pour ses familles
pour ses papas à ses mamans qui sont
dans le monde du travail parfois un peu
difficile et puis pour ces jeunes gens
qui sont en train d'écrire à leur avenir
plutôt que de s'abandonner à la
mélancolie David André a pris le pari de
mettre en chanson les pérégrinations de
ces lycéens la fantaisie qui s'en dégage
contraste avec la noirceur de leur
environnement des industrialisations
chômage et angoisses parental
son idée c'est peut-être pas la tienne
c'est ça que je veux te faire comprendre
reçu en grande pompe à l'Elysée ces
adolescents vrai personnage de chant de
ton bac d'abord ont déjà fait un premier
pied de nez à l'avenir sombre qui leur
était promis la conscience de la crise
de la des industrialisation ça peut être
jeunesse quand même qui est déboussolée
désemparé non je vais voir ce
documentaire parce que il me semble très
intéressant je pense qu'ils en ont un
peu assez qu'on appelle Chris ceux qui
est en fin de compte une véritable
mutation de notre société et le mot
crise est tellement a été tellement
galvaudé ces dernières années je pense
que cette génération a conscience d'être
une société en totale mutation
et il faut l'aider à réinventer et à
participer à ces limitations parce qu'on
voit bien que le travail va changer on
voit bien que Rosetta ce qui s'est passé
cette semaine en nous n'avons pas eu le
temps de parler ouvre les un horizon
absolument formidable et donc ils
veulent être au cœur de la mutation
parce que c'est eux qui en seront les
acteurs c'est sur cette belle image de
du petit robot filae qui réenchante le
rêve européen que l'on va se quitter
merci beaucoup d'avoir été notre invité
merci à tous bonne journée